so what's up guys the t-shirts back
Louie that's a t-shirt I've been wearing
a suit lately it's fun I might do it
from time to time but you know what I
miss my t-shirt and I just t-shirts
wanderlust stars Paul Rudd Jennifer
Aniston it's directed by David Wade and
he has a lot of fans he has a lot of you
know like cult fans and people just like
yes David Wade anything you do I am
there you know for the movies like wet
hot American summer and role models
which I really like that movie was a lot
of fun it's about this couple and
they're really stressed with life
they're sick of the whole business world
they're tired of money and they decide
to run off and they get stuck at this
commune filled with hippies everyone's
very free there's free spirits the free
spirits roam the land you know they sing
songs they play guitar all that stuff
hippie stuff I was looking forward to
this movie because I haven't seen a good
comedy in a while and I really like role
models I love Paul Rudd and Jennifer
Aniston is just it's getting hotter is
like is it possible for someone to
continuously get hotter as they get
older I don't know what it is but she is
like smokin hot in this movie and
there's definitely a lot of comedy to
behind this movie there's a lot of funny
parts there's a lot of parts I laughed
out loud in fact there was one scene
involving Paul Rudd psyching himself up
in front of a mirror I was crying I was
crying with like tears of laughter this
is a funny movie and I did enjoy it for
the first half I really enjoyed it the
movie sets itself up really well like
you can really feel all the needed
comedy pieces just coming right into
place and like yes this is gonna be this
is gonna be great it just kind of tapers
off a little bit and then kind of just
fades into this comedy that was at one
time really hilarious but then kind of
got a little bit stale Paul Rudd just
holds this movie together he is so good
here this is one of the funniest
performances I've seen him give he
honestly saved this movie from being
mediocre he was so good in this film I
loved his performance you could tell he
was improv you could tell it was just
alright it's coming up with stuff he was
great see Jennifer Aniston kind of
started with this thing where everyone
thought she was just playing Rachel from
friends and every movie she was in and
in some way she was but with Horrible
Bosses last year it seemed like she was
trying to break out of that barrier and
it seemed like she was trying to the
same thing this movie and I would say
she mostly succeeded I think that she
was good in the movie and I'd never have
a problem looking at her now I know
you're gonna ask me where she naked in
the movie I was gonna say no there was
not
goodness in this movie from her and so
I'm sorry you'll be disappointed by that
if you're looking forward to it there
was however way too much male nakedness
see some of the characters got way too
over-the-top to the point where you were
just like seriously no this no I mean I
understand a lot of it was for comedy
but I think there's a needed sense of
realism in any type of comedy even in a
very sophomoric comedy where the humor
is just silly and about you know poop
and boogers and all that kind of stuff
even when you got a movie like that I
think there's a needed sense of realism
so you can ground it in reality so that
the jokes feel fresh and real even if
they're stupid and wanderlust has a lot
of really funny moments but a lot of the
jokes mainly towards the latter half
where they try to expose certain members
of this community villains it just got a
little bit fake and it lost that kind of
needed sense of realism another
performance I really liked in this movie
was the wife of Paul Rudd's brother I
can't remember her name but she played
this woman who was sick of her marriage
sick of her kids she had margaritas like
all day like even for breakfast and
stuff and she just randomly spouts off
some really hilarious one-liners she was
been the movie good job woman overall I
enjoyed wanderlust it was not a bad
movie at all it just it was just
disappointing it wasn't as good as role
models I wanted a little bit more but I
like Paul Rudd in the movie so I'm gonna
give wanderlust a b-minus what's your
favourite Paul Rudd movie I think
- anchorman sex panther 60% of the time
it works every time if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck man eyes